hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast cross validation of antibodies
using did you West presented by doctors
markers template in Anthony cuvee own
I'm Christina jewel of lab routes and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth and sponsored by cell
signaling technology cell signaling cell
signaling technology CST is a private
family-owned company founded by
scientists and dedicated to providing
the world's highest quality innovative
research and diagnostic products to
accelerate biological understanding and
enable personalized medicine for more
information go to www.hsn milcom here's
how the presentation works we want to
hear from you questions comments and
even answers can be submitted via the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your screen we'll try to get to everyone
but if not we'll make sure to follow up
with you by email you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you can't hear or
see this presentation properly let us
know by clicking on the support button
at the top right or the Q&A button in
the lower left we have two speakers
today dr. Marcus Thames lien head of
assay development and dr. Anthony cuvee
young scientific marketing project
manager at cell signal technology
signaling technology this two-part
webinar will focus on the use of novel
methodologies being developed to
challenge the specificity of research
antibodies and how those technologies
apply to antibody producers such as cell
signaling technology our first speaker
today is dr. Marcus Templin dr. Thompson
heads the department of assay
development at the nmi natural and
Medical Sciences Institute at the
University of Tuebingen in a
multidisciplinary environment scientists
from applied physics chemistry biology
and biochemistry are working together in
his department
to develop advanced assay system for
industrial clients marques campaigns
research is focused on the application
of micro arrays for proteomic and cancer
research and he holds several patents in
this area
he studied biology at the University of
Tuebingen did his postdoctoral research
at the Edinburgh University of Scotland
and the Max Planck Institute for
developmental biology Germany before
joining the natural and Medical Sciences
Institute I will now turn the
presentation over to dr. Tom Paine dr.
temte
hello it is a pleasure to talk about
some recent work we did in our tubulin
lab and it is about the development of a
novel method a variation of the Western
blot I will go into some detail of that
but more important I think for this
seminar a first application or not the
first application but an early
application which really is
classification and characterization of
antibodies very briefly to my background
so it was mentioned that I'm working at
the nmi at the University of Tuebingen
interestingly enough it is not part of
University the MMI but an independent
organization as foundation and we are
bringing research into use so focus is
applied research the Institute is
shifting quite a lot into biology and
we're actually working as a CRO at the
moment doing work with assay systems we
have developed but that's enough for an
introduction I would like to go what did
interest me over the last 15 years and
how we tend to use technologies we have
in-house to develop a new variation of
the Western blot so you see here a slide
from the CSD website which shows the map
cascade signaling pathway it is a
complicated thing a lot of proteins and
all of these proteins come in different
flavors they can be activated which very
often means phosphorylated and detecting
phosphorylation tells you a lot about
the state of activity of a pathway
inside the cell which determines the
behavior of the cell to get an idea what
really is happening inside the
you want to measure these modification
and maybe also the absolute demand of
proteins and for that there are
different methods mass spec has become
very important but the classical way and
still probably the most sensitive way is
looking at proteins using the classical
Western button for that you need
antibodies so you get balanced and if
you get a good antibody you got an idea
what really happens what you see here is
just a few bands from small and simple
experiment which by the way was still
quite a bit of work so several days of
work but if you know think about going
into much more detail we need much more
antibodies and then works really starts
to get big and the amount of material
you require is growing and growing so we
were thinking about how to get the
classical Western blood into a format
where it can accommodate more more
incubations and we started and we wanted
to do that with a very classical way of
separating denatured proteins in an
sds-page gel and this is what you see
here the Western blot then requires the
transfer of the separated proteins onto
a membrane which should be shown be
shown here in the next part of the
picture so you've got blotting membrane
which is usually incubated with an
antibody to give a picture of a band
which has been detected by this antibody
now things start to get a bit different
we're not looking at whole gels we're
starting to look at only one leg which
is one sample and this one sample shows
all the proteins which are present in
the sample
we used to generate fractions and
interestingly these fractions are
somehow size fractions so we cut the
band from top to the bottom into small
stripes of membrane in these stripes of
membrane actually make up 96 different
stripes out out of one-lane have now the
equivalent of 96 size fractions with
this material we go into a microtiter
plate there comes the 96 form and each
of the snippets we have is put into one
well of the microtiter plate so each of
the world really contains one define
sized fraction of proteins
we can now elude all the proteins from
the stripes that's part of a patent we
have on this method and we add beads to
each of these wells in the 96-well
plates interestingly there is technology
available and we use the luminex
technology for that that each well gets
a different colored bead so in a way you
can now transfer the proteins which were
in solution came from the strip's onto
the surface of the beads and since the
beads are 96 different flavors 96
different colors you have now the
transfer of the side fractions onto
distinguishable beads which means you
get when you peel a pool of these all of
these is section of beads which are
still identifiable so yellow beads my
carry carry proteins of the size of 60
kilo daltons blue beads might carry
proteins exclusively of the size of 18
to 20 kilo daltons so quite a bit of
work what we have done to that point and
what we end up with is kind of a Western
block membrane in an Eppendorf cup
what's the advantage of this amount of
work it's very simple the amount of
beads we do have here is sufficient to
run assay is not one SI as in the
classical Western blot but quite a few
ounces and we run 200 400 or even 600
antibody incubations with just one of
these Eppendorf cups for one sample so
instead of having just one si maybe two
antibodies maybe three antibodies on one
sample Lane you can how now have 100 for
the amount of assays running from this
amount of material which is 10 to 20
microgram what we classically use so how
does it work
so we take a loquats let's say a
fraction of a percent into an 96 well
plate again and to each of the wells we
put in a different antibody what happens
now is the antibody does recognize
that bees which carry the right protein
so for each of the wells you get 96
different signals and these 96 different
signals can be plotted according to size
in what you see and this is indicated
here is you get kind of chromatogram and
this chromatogram gives you information
on first of all where signal is detected
and what size the beads carry proteins
off so let's make that a bit clearer and
for that I prepared a slide which is
shown in the next one so we do have if
you do run a classic Western blot a
stripe where all the proteins which have
been separated are shown here we did two
stripes of these western blots and we're
using two different antibodies
recognizing a protein which runs at 80
the 38 kilovolt in year 2 alpha protein
we've got two different antibodies one
recognizing whole protein and one
recognizing a phosphorylated version of
the protein what you actually see is yes
there is a band this band is specific it
comes at the right place we think so and
you see the same band for the
phosphorylated version at the same place
and again the molecular weight is to the
same indicating that they're really both
same protein one time the phosphorylated
version the other time the total version
of the protein if you not take this
separated Lane you can cut it into 96
different size reaction as I explained
before and what you see in the next
slide is small dots where the membrane
was cut and when you know incubate the
beans with the antibody you see signal
occurring at the snippets which were
carrying the 38 kilo Dalton fractions
and indeed there is a peak occurring for
both of the versions of the protein you
also see some side bands and you see
that in both the classical Western blot
and in the DJ West diagram
representation we have there you now can
use the numeric data which was generated
by the Luminex machine and make a
picture back out of this data again
in the next slide and that looks very
much like the initial Western blot so in
a way that's a very simple way of
getting the information you usually get
from a Western blot as a numerical data
and as I said the big advantage is
instead of running one you can run
hundreds on antibodies on this material
you use for your separation in the SDS
page so to make that a bit more clear
the next slide shows you one antibody
and that's just microtiter plate full of
intubations with me with the western
digi West beads we're making so okay it
looks nice but what what is it what is
it mean is the sensitivity good enough
this is linear and how good is
reproducibility and for that I will show
an example in this example is a very
classical example we use the lighter
system which is still one of the best
readouts for Western blotting to
incubate a Western blot in which we use
the cell I mean it was a hep gene to
cell line in that case where we spiked
differing amounts of each fusion protein
of the earth to protein to so the
differing amounts are really spanning
three orders of magnitude from 20
nanograms spiked into 20 picogram and
what you see is three bands in the
classical Western bodies the to
intrinsic earth bands work one and two
and also the fusion protein which is
bigger which we spiked in you now can
use the picture from from molecular and
quantify and you get numeric data out of
that so we did you do the same thing
again and we're processing the samples
in in the digi West and what we got is
the did us diagrams and you see just one
here on the top again
it is the same thing you've got a big
bound which is the lower band from the
to intrinsic one you get a lower
intensity band which the second one so
you see the earth one and two and at 74
kilo Dalton you do see the fusion
protein with a certain amount and that
is for the one point two five nanograms
you can do that for all the other lanes
and you see that the intensity drops if
you spike in lower material
but it really goes down to the 20
picogram there's still a clear-cut peak
scene the same is true if you go up to
higher amounts the 20 nanograms so the
signal gets very high so we put an inset
to really show that so you really see
that over three orders of magnitude you
get Peaks and you can actually quantify
these Peaks and if you do that if you
quantify the piece from from the
different lanes here used by the digi
West get the diagram on what you really
see on the right-hand side is there's a
very good linearity what you don't see
is these measurements were done in
triplicate so the variation is is low
and we usually get an interview which is
well below 10% so if you do the same
thing with the the like or system it is
not better not worse it is actually
fairly similar so what we do have here
is a technology the digi West which is
when looking at linearity and sin
sensitivity on par with the like or
technology but keep in mind the same
amount of material you would need with
with the classical Western what is now
sufficient for hundreds of assets okay
that is good we really like that we
develop the method further and it is now
really in this state that we do offer
that as a service but if you do have the
possibility of running hundreds of of
assays in parallel you need to have the
hundreds of antibodies and for that we
started and that just actually started
approximately ten years ago ways of
qualifying the antibodies we usually
buying and we buy a lot of antibodies so
how a fridge is filled with more than
1500 antibodies and what we started with
is a very classical way of qualifing
qualifying our antibodies for our use so
we were working still working a lot with
Mouse material Mouse tumors malice tumor
cell lines but more often we actually
working with human material and that is
human cell lines human tumor cell lines
human primary tissue has become very
very important so we set up a set of
materials we used for qualifying our
antibodies so what is you see
here is three different mouth samples
which is normal little for mouth and two
different types of tumors mouth tumor
liver tumors where we were running
classical Western blots and what you see
here are small stripes which we cut out
of our Western blot the same is true for
the human material again a set of human
cell lines what you see here is five and
two primary tissues one Juma tissue and
one normal tissue if you do that you add
an antibody and that's really a very
very good antibody one monoclonal Rabbit
we will be purchased from from CSD which
gives you what you really want to have
from an antibody and we see here that
the antibody is working on all the
materials the mouse materials and the
human materials and this antibody we
qualify as a good working antibody and
that made it in out to our collection we
did this kind of analysis for
600-something antibodies so we do have
quite a big basis of Western blot
qualified antibodies but now when we had
our digitized available we were thinking
okay there may be a quicker faster
simpler and maybe even better way of
getting an idea if the antibody is
working on on the different materials we
are interested in and we have on hand we
use now the digi West for qualifying our
antibodies and that is seen in the next
slide looks very similar and what you
see is again four of the samples which
we are using for the human samples which
were using for qualifying our human
antibodies by classical Western blot
again the same thing some of them the
mouse samples we've got quite quite a
bit of information on it is for now but
we added here different material we are
interested in it is rat kidney it is rat
liver we'll also have dog kidney and
liver monkey kidney event mini pygmy
kidney and liver so this really points
to to one of our areas of expertise
we're doing toxicology and toxicology
after is using the D G West so what you
see again an antibody from CSD a good
antibody
a monoclonal rabbit which gives a
perfect band at human and mouse and if
you now go to rat the band is very weak
not unspecific but it is weak dark
monkey and mini-pig is also giving the
right band at the right place so what
you do have here now is well beyond what
we had with the classical Western bloc
information on the performance of this
antibody in different species and there
also in different types of tissue in
this PC I put second example on that
again an antibody against the kinase
which is at that time not from CST which
gives some side bands which
interestingly doesn't give any
reactivity in rat very poor - and not
really any reactivity in in dark but it
is working again in monkey and mini peak
but there is giving have a side bands so
we've got now the idea how the
antibodies work on different species to
show it in a more systematic thing in a
more systematic view we did that with
the twelve hundred something antibodies
we are using regularly right at the
moment it is when you go to human
fraction good fraction of antibodies
which doesn't give any side bands on any
of the observed materials so there is
also a larger fraction of the antibodies
which is a quarter of all we tested
roughly which do give some sign bands
and some some some some tissues but
they're perfectly usable and since you
do have the information from the size
separation using the digi West there are
really no problem to use there's quite a
big section of proteins where we don't
get any signal which is perfectly
possible so not everything is expressed
in any tissue and if you're thinking
about phosphorylation this really might
be very important because some proteins
are only phosphorylated under certain
circumstances critical it gas with other
things where the size is not there or
the signal is is really poor so to
summarize if it is a fast approach to to
look at quite a few
Jubilees the sample consumption is very
low for all of this what I was showing
here you're thinking really on on maybe
200 microgram of material which is
needed and you get this information
relatively quick and you can use dozens
of samples be different tissues be
different species be different cell
lines and they can all screen in
parallel okay so much for the antibody
validation but it was talking about the
digi West and the DG West so same thing
well it was bit too quick same thing on
the mainly peak and what you see here
that from from roughly 700 we tested
some 60% are working which is
interesting because now we have a
collection a validated collection of
antibodies which can be used and
material which has been created all get
from from from many things okay but to
summarize that you do have the
possibility and we do have a set of 700
to 800 antibodies for mouse and human
material which is a must be a number
which really makes sense if you can run
hundreds of assays on on the DG west if
you go to to the species which might be
more interesting for pharmacology
toxicology red sign Emolga this dog and
mini pig we're still well beyond 300 for
these species and you can compare the
quality of the antibody by that
relatively easily okay but it would now
like to go back to to to the GG West and
just to summarize we can use all types
of materials in cells from cell culture
via tissues you be tumors from from
tumor models and run them on a classical
sds-page block them as as classical
transfer all of the proteins which were
in the sample onto beads pull the beads
and use the big pool as equivalent of
Western bloc membranes and generate
numbers bands which we can then use for
getting larger datasets which are not
really proteomic data sets but they are
not too far away from
in in bigger protein profiling
experiments the method is finally
getting published it is impressed and if
things go right it will be very soon
maybe even tomorrow that it will go
online okay so in the paper we will
publish we have also some examples how
the DG s can be used and one things
we're interested in my lab is resistance
development in the collaboration with
dama Cousteau from the team in unique
one of the the big guys in mass back we
designed an experiment where material s
a line which was designed in Bella's lab
which is which was rendered resistant
against lapatinib was compared to the
parental cell line so the cells were
grown over a long period of time in
month half year nearly in the presence
of increasing amount of lapatinib and
they learn to deal with that and we took
lysate from the cells and analyzed that
by adage west and we took lysate from
the parental strain and analyzed by DG s
so it is simply on comparative analysis
at the same time were actually before we
did that Bernhardt
or Ben and Ben where we're analyzing
these tire cells again they used an
enrichment of kinases a method which
they developed in their lab the kind of
beasts and so that only the kinase were
pulled out or out of their cell license
and what they then did they compared the
amount of the kinase they fished and
it's essentially all kinase is present
in in the cell lines and they made
ratios out of the parental out of the
resistance of a parental strain that
same in in the next slide so there is a
set of 24 kindnesses which are different
between the strains set like the athlean
a for is up regulated under resistant
conditions another set like if every in
a2 is down regulated and what you see
here is simply the ratio has a log to is
is there and what you see we get
upregulation up to a factory or for a
diamond regulation up to a factor of ten
interestingly we did the same experiment
but not using mass spec but by using our
digi West and what you see here in in
blue is the ratio we calculated from the
digi wet experiment and interestingly it
is very close to each other so in a way
we not only have a good correlation
between the digits and the mass spec
data but we get somehow a benchmark a
validation that the that the digi West
experiment could give you similar
information as the mass bank approach a
nice thing and that came to our mind
when we were doing these experiments is
we don't need to purify the kinase is
out of the crude life stage we can use
the crew to I say directly and that
gives the possibility not only to look
at the tiny sis and what you see here in
the next picture is what we got out of
there the kinase in enrichment but also
to look at the whole ice age and with
the whole I said you as well get the
possibility to look at kinase is the RSK
ones and well visible over there but you
also see different things and what was
interesting for us and for for for our
work was that you see the would be
counteracting proteins they do a
specific kinase is of a lot of the dual
specific phosphatases a lot of well
connected with map kinase signaling but
but getting rid of the phosphate or
occurring here as well so the
information comes well beyond the kinam
it gives you the possibility to also
look at other proteins and here the
phosphatases were especially interesting
another type of protein which was
especially interesting was the p50 tail
and our analysis over the data set we
had and we were using more than 200
antibodies all that was pointing to a
role in
development for p53 and we did an
ingenuity plot in agility analysis and
when you look at the amount of cliffs 53
you really see that the resistance
strain has a strongly downregulated
amount of p53 which is an indication
what really happens in this cell so this
was a first example which some are
validated the approach but also really
gave new information very briefly and
two other things I would like to go was
mentioning the importance of resistance
in our lab and we are also looking at
primary material primary tumor material
which we got from the clinic here in
Indian on changes in the kind now not
only but also in other proteins that are
observed within primary ovarian cancer
so resistance I won't go into detail in
that is a big problem when treating
ovarian cancer and is really not quite
clear when and how the resistance will
occur what we had was in retrospective
studies so we had material from patients
which showed relapse after after the
operation and we had the initial tumor
material which was removed from from
from the patients and we were looking at
these type of material from patients
which had a relapse and patients which
were cured after half a year to two to
three years time we did the same thing
we tested first of all a lot of
antibodies it was more than 1200 we
chose 466 antibodies we were looking for
in a smaller set that was 24 in that
case for differences in expression or in
activation that is briefly seen here you
get so much material so much data that
that the the classical heat maps from
from mRNA expression are the only way to
visualize them and if you condense that
down we ended up with a smaller set so
around 10 proteins which really
discriminated material cancer tissues
which
developed resistance later on from the
material which state sensitive to the
Platinum which was used as a treatment
and interestingly in love it was
exclusively mainly no no not exclusively
mainly phosphorylated versions of
protein which we found on that side that
work is still ongoing and will be
published sometime soon and the
indication we do have that nutcase
signaling is important and if Kappa B
signaling is involved and also mitosis
and proliferation are changed between
the sensitives and deep the insensitive
tubers okay last example I would really
want to give is Becky really can use the
system with not a lot of material so a
showed you can use that in both cell
lines a showed you can use that with
primary materials when I was primary
tumors but what we did as a last way of
reading looking how how good the method
is we were taking sections which has
been prepared from tumors in that case
it was Naamah carcinoma and we had a
look at the the pathologist had to look
at the the tumors which were found in
the sections which were the invasive
ductal carcinoma or very often directly
adjacent to the invasive ductal
carcinoma the ductal carcinoma in situ
so the the supposed preformed you find
fairly frequently in in the sections by
using laser capture microdissection we
were capable of isolating cells of one
type and also cells from the other type
from once patient so it really is a
matched way of comparing the type of
tumors which were found beside each
other the number cells found was
relatively low just a few thousand which
we could collect by laser capture and
the amount of material you get out of
that is in the range of a microgram
maybe a bit more maybe a bit less and
then we try if it is possible to run a
digi West with this low amount of
material and actually yes it is possible
so 160 intubations we did and we get
really differences
see here the the invasive versus the in
situ carcinoma some proteins and there's
examples some obvious things like the
carotenes would be excited carotene 18
is unchanged 19 is getting down in the
invasive form on the other hand 14 is
going up in the invasive form so to
summarize very briefly so we did a
matched pair analysis from laser capture
microdissection cells we get from from
the slides directly we had not a lot of
material so range of the microgram and
were able to test a hundred and sixty
antibodies on that and we have quite a
comprehensive information on pathway
activation and phosphorylation so that
brings me to the end so I was talking
quite a bit about a novel technology as
I mentioned to be published very soon it
is a version of the Western block which
starts with classical protein separation
in it in an SDS page and blotting
through a membrane then transfer to two
beats which are in our case readout with
the Luminex system and for that you can
really use what you usually put onto the
gel 15 20 micrograms to run hundreds of
of different different assays for that
we needed qualified antibodies and part
of my talk was really how we qualified
these antibodies these days and for that
we built well we call it the Streamlight
antibody characterizing platform we
still rely on the information which come
from the company but if you're really
looking at different types of material
different tissues it is very useful to
have an idea if the antibody we want to
use is working or is not using so at the
end three examples how we can use the DG
west so there is a broad range of
applications in translational research
and very briefly is very important these
are the key people which were involved
in the work so free d'Alene's thought
that as as a PhD student and all the
others in the
are still heavily working with that and
maybe quite interesting after while we
found out that the method is not only
working and is not only good were giving
good results but really fits into our
portfolio of commercialized assets so it
was mentioning that the nmi and the N
MIT G is working as a CRO and we now do
offer D G West services mainly performed
in our Berlin site and if you're
interested in that there you see the web
page where you can find more information
ok and that's it for me thanks for
listening thank you dr. Templin our next
speaker is dr. Anthony Covey young dr.
Covey unattended Colby College in
Waterville Maine USA where he majored in
biology and chemistry
post-graduation he came he became a
research associate in the laboratories
of dr. Christopher L carpenter and Louis
cantly at the Harvard Medical School
where he was introduced to the
fascinating world of signal transduction
lipid kinases and the role of RAD like
proteins and disease under the tutelage
of dr. John age Exton at Vanderbilt
University in Nashville Tennessee dr.
karubian received his PhD in molecular
physiology and biophysics while studying
the role of ro family proteins and the
regulators in neuronal function he then
returned to Harvard and Beth Israel
Deaconess Medical Center where he
rejoined the cantly lab to continue his
work on row family JTP gtp aces and
their role in immune cell development
and function neuronal plasticity and
cardiac development dr. cuvee Owen Jones
cell signal signaling technology in 2009
as a development scientist developing
and validating antibody products in the
map k lipid signaling and other pathways
he has also worked extensively in the
proteomics space developing novel
antibody reagents against novel post
translational modification and a reagent
that detect specific substrate motifs
high-throughput proteomics analysis dr.
cuvee own currently works as the science
scientific project manager focused on
initiatives promoting anybody reproduct
ability in research I will now turn the
presentation over to dr. Anthony cuvee
own dr. Caggiano thank you and welcome
everybody to the webinar there are two
main points that I'd like to talk about
today and following up to Marcus's
presentation and that is why did some
antibodies like those from CST work well
in a platform like digi West and the
second point is what is the importance
of cross-validation on a platform such
as this and if there's one message that
I hope that you take away from this part
of the webinar it's that all antibodies
must be validated in the application
that you're using
just because an antibody is validated
and one application does not mean it
will work well in another most reputable
antibody suppliers will often validate
their antibodies in a set of core
applications such as Western blot muna
precipitation mystic chemistry I mean a
site of chemistry flow cytometry and or
chip of course the applications tested
depend on the targets in the antibody
for example you wouldn't necessarily
consider testing and EGF receptor
antibody for chip
however testing an antibody application
does not mean that as is validated for
every application the specificity and
sensitivity of the antibody must be
determined the process of properly
validating an antibody is long and
complex and relies on the use of the
right controls cells and tissues that
differentially express the target of
interest knockout models CRISPR and si
RNA choosing the correct model systems
and validation for validation and use of
agonists and inhibitors the most
important factor in our hands is cross
validation that is testing and
validating the antibody in multiple
applications such as those that Marcus
has just described this information
provides confidence in the specify
sensitivity of the antibody most vendors
will indicate which applications have
been tested but not necessarily
validated for their products customers
and end-users should always review the
data to see if the vendor has a
validated as an antibody in the
application you're using if not you'll
need to do it yourself
again reputable vendors will often
indicate the applications that have been
validated for the antibody and provide
both the data and the protocols to
support this result in addition to the
core applications I just described CST
often cross validate SATs antibody is in
a number of additional applications to
prove specificity and functionality
these include the use of chip seek me
dip peptide arrays competitive Eliza's
DNA dot blots in cell westerns multiplex
HC etc etc multi tissue a multi tissue
arrays illustrated a few of those here
the applications are used to cross
validate or highly dependent on the
antibody target and the desired
functionality oftentimes validation by
multiple applications either internally
or externally can increase your
confidence in the specificity of the
antibody but please remember
functionality in one assay does not
predict efficacy in another one of the
reasons that we at CSP get very excited
about platforms like digi West is seeing
our products tested and validated in
another application many of our products
are used widely in other novel assays
such as nano string and mass spec
imaging techniques such as those being
developed by ion path there's a paper
here that you can reference for that
information we get excited because
generally our antibodies perform well in
these systems due to the high level of
validation that we do in-house and it's
nice to see that confirmed by external
users or all of our antibodies perfect
no but it does not mean that the
antibody isn't specific it may mean that
the antibody does not work in this
particular assay
and typically when we find a publication
such as this we still review all the
data and revalidate the antibody just to
be sure so why is independent validation
in every application so critical and I'm
sharing with you here an example of a
product that I developed a few years ago
these are Western blots from an HS an
animal immunized with hsp70 antigens and
this was a antigen that we knew to
perform well by and mean a fluorescence
enemies to chemistry previously and so
we need to develop a new antibody that
had multiple applications so we Anna we
isolated antibody clones from one rabbit
and tested them here by Western blot I'm
showing you four representative clones
keep in mind that all four of the clones
I'm showing you here are the same exam
exact rabbit in the same peptide we
tested specificity independently I'm
just not showing it here one of the
desired applications was
immunofluorescence we tested the same
four clones again that looked identical
by Western blot and came up with a
situation in which we had very different
localizations we went on to further
validate using heat shock and other
methods to alter the location of hsp70
in the cells but none of the clones
proved to be correct so this is one of
many examples that we've seen of how an
antibody looks good in one applications
in application that performs poorly in
another again this illustrates the need
for application specific validation
including all of the techniques that
I've mentioned previously and I've
reiterated those here but one that's
often overlooked is the use of a correct
protocol so why are correct protocol so
critical in antibody development how
often are the methods sections and
papers detailed enough for you to be
able to replicate an experiment done in
another lab I'd argue that this is not
very frequent the same is true for
antibody suppliers at CSP we tried
multiple protocols when testing our
antibodies and when
we recommend an antibody for a
particular application we not only
provide the data but also a detailed
protocol with the steps and reagents
used so you can repeat the experiment in
your lab this is important because
different fixation and permeabilization
conditions can adversely affect your
results as you can see here just
changing the permeabilization condition
from Triton to glucoside made a huge
difference in the correct staining of
our bcl-xl antibody and that's the
protocol that appears on our website for
that product sometimes the results are
not so subtle and the buffer conditions
can make a difference between complete
success and complete failure at CST we
are committed to this your success and
we provide these specific protocols used
in order to validate the antibody if as
always if there's a question about
whether an antibody works in a
particular application or whether it's
been tested or the conditions under
which it works we encourage you to call
our tech support so they can help you
any of these conditions can adversely
affect the outcome of an experiment
often overlooked is the quality of the
sample how long it's been stored the out
of the buffer it's in the fixation in
permeabilization time the freshness of
buffers obviously has a huge impact and
again I will argue that the vendor
should absolutely provide a detailed
protocol for you to use when you're
carrying using one of their products to
remove these variables and make your
experiments easier to carry out
interpret enclosing CST is validation
principles illustrated here are
specificity sensitivity quality
authenticity methodology and
transparency and all of these things
lead to greater reproducibility for you
and for all academic and industrial
research if you're interested in
learning more please visit our website
or log in and sign up for the next
leverage webinar which will not next but
the webinar that I'll be presenting in
October which we'll get into this
the role that the antibodies play and
the entire reproducibility crisis coming
up in October and with that I will say
that again if you need assistance with
an antibody or you have questions about
this our validation procedures please
call us let us know we be happy to hear
from you and with that I will close and
Marcus and I will take questions
thank you dr. Cooley on for that
informative presentation okay we want to
get right to your questions and input so
here's a reminder how to let us know
what you have to say questions etc can
be submitted via the Q&A button at the
lower left we will try to get to all of
you but if not we will be sure to follow
up with you after the broadcast okay our
first question is a two-part question is
the membrane manually cut into
ninety-six slices or automated and how
do you accurately assign molecular
weight to these 96 slices okay that's
actually a nice question so first of all
the automation is there so there are
devices which are called
cutting plotters which we use for
cutting the membranes they are very
accurate so they usually use the same
technology as inkjet plotter is to
position the knives so it's very simple
to get equally distant pieces of the
membrane and in the paper we will go
into that also in innocent detail the
second question is actually very
interesting questions while we started
with running an extra lane with the
marker and we're looking where the
markers were running and then simply
transferring the the distance to their
sniffler suite generated we can do it in
a totally different way so the digit
West is capable of running hundreds of
assays so hundreds of antibodies are
usually used during one assay so now for
each of the antibodies you know that the
protein which is to be recognized as
certain molecular weight so what we
usually do is pick something like 15 of
these proteins which are detected by the
DG West knowing their molecular weight
knowing on which snippet in which beat
they were running in using them as an
internal market
this really has doubly advantage that
each and every separation which is
obviously dependent also on the SDS page
will give you the actual size of the
protein which you know where it is and
the accuracy of this kind of of
assigning the molecular weight is very
very good and again we describe that
also in the paper in some detail thank
you dr. Templin next question how do you
ensure reliability of results over time
meaning when do you need to use new
batches of antibodies mainly for
polyclonal yes I can take that question
and that's a very very good question the
way that we and I can only speak for CST
the way that we ensure specificity with
reliability consistency over time is by
validating every lot of a new product or
of a product in every application for
which it's approved and it's very
important that you formulate the
antibody in a way so that it works
exactly the same from lots of lots a lot
now this is particularly difficult for
polyclonal antibodies because there is
generally drift in polyclonal antibodies
over time and so the CST were very very
very careful to ensure that our products
are consistent from lots a lot as a
matter of fact I just saw data the other
day where we went back and did a
comparison for a product that we
released in 1999 that was a lot 1 and
they compared every lot from lot 1 to
lot 29 and by Western blot and by if'
it's exactly the same so if you're very
careful about it you can do it you know
in a you can you can create that
consistency by being very careful the
other way to solve
issue is by transitioning over to
recombinant or monoclonal antibodies
that are by their very nature and
production method much more consistent
from lots a lot I hope that answers the
question
thank you dr. commune next question is
the information on the antibody
validation by didja West publicly
available okay it's not publicly
available at the moment but with a paper
to be published very very soon there
will be a list attached in which we list
approximately 300 of the antibodies that
are working in the G West on the
materials we were using there these were
several cell lines tumor cell lines and
also primary human human tissue so this
will be a starter then there will be a
paper it was talking about the antibody
validation characterization using the
different species well it has been
published in a short way there will be a
proper paper on that and that paper will
include quite quite substantial
information on the antibodies and very
obvious to say if you would like to to
order kind of a DDoS characterization
from us you do get each and every
information on the antibodies in why
they did get it into into our list of
antibodies in this list of antibodies of
working antibodies is available from
from from our homepage as well so there
is not all information public at the
moment there's some public available but
there will be more very soon next
question what would happen if the
results have a digitized experiment
called the specificity of a CST antibody
into question I'll answer that one so I
think that some of the results that I've
seen do do that and in those cases what
we've done is we've gone back and we've
looked and we've reviewed to make sure
that that the antibody that we're
selling is correct for the applications
for which we've approved it
and in in all the cases that I've seen
so far that's been it that's been the
case
you know not all antibodies are perfect
and I think that you know we do as much
as we possibly can and I think that we
the antibodies that we have on the
market right now I would stand behind
every single one of them but if we were
to work with Marcus and find one that
where the specificity was called into
question our typical procedure would be
to do an internal review notify the
customers that there's maybe something
wrong and then work with those customers
to make it right you know our worst fear
is making a product that doesn't work
the way that we says we say it does so
we take that kind of thing very very
seriously and we appreciate when other
platforms come in to cross validate our
antibodies because it makes us more
confident and it reveals any weaknesses
that we have thank you do you think more
companies will start using platforms
like didja West to routinely validate
the specificity of antibody well as a
modern company person I could try to
answer that it's not the only way where
you can run kind of multiple Western
blots other technologies have been
developed over the years and there are a
lot of things happening this really is
for the good of the big antibody
producing companies so you do get much
more information than you had over the
recent years and want the reason we
really had to start that from scratch
that a lot of the antibodies which we
bought initially we're not good we
needed to have better information so I
think there will be similar technologies
around and there are around and it will
get better information on the antibody
see you can find
now if you do run didja west a phase do
you use possibly specific panels of
antibody that's an interesting question
so yes it is very interesting very often
you've got an idea
that a treatment or a tumor is of a
certain type and you might be interested
in looking at three or four specific
pathways which might be hit by a
mutation or by abide by it but by a drug
candidate you're interested in what we
started and we're real actively doing is
setting up panels of antibodies which
which which we think make sense for
analysis still there is the big list and
everything which is on the big list can
be chosen but the the panels are
interesting to really have an idea how
how things might be changed to be but
quite a bit of work on setting these
panels together this is work for a
plasma serum not really so you've got
the same problem with very with quite a
few of the proteomic technologies so the
handful of proteins or the two dozen of
proteins which make most of the plasma
protein content do interfere with
analysis so if you love plasma on the
SDS page you see yeah well albumin
mainly is some some some IgG bands and a
lot of the other things are not anything
you see if you deplete things look
totally different and it can work like
black and we're actually thinking the
other way around
so getting reactivity on serum plasma
proteins and testing this reactivity for
two antibodies however you might call
that on different tissues or on extracts
from from from so
disease-causing agents you can get
information on that which is a DDoS turn
the other way around which is working
and which is actually working very
nicely thank you
next question what is the cost of a
study using did you West okay
not tricky questions it really depends
on the size of the study if we do that
via our NMIT subsidiary so running
hundreds of antibodies on a dozens of
sample gives you a price which is in the
range of 6 to 10 euros the number of
antibodies is getting lower since it
really is meant to to test a lot of
antibodies prices can go up to let's say
12 or 14 euro per analysis so that's a
rough estimate so if you really think in
as a company and you're thinking and
calculating the price of a Western blot
you will find out okay that is a bit
cheaper than a classical Western blot
and if you go to a higher throughput
200-300 antibodies it is much cheaper
and you really have to see you don't
need to care about antibodies they're
all here on our list we have some great
questions coming in but we have time for
one more and this is a two-part question
what type of mass spec are you using
when you compare the G West and mass
spec I would think the advantage is to
mass spec as you uncover unknown where
as did West's limits although you can
test many to the antibody as you choose
to test okay so the mass spec work was
done in inbound on Krista's lab in
Munich I think he wasn't using an OB
traffic for for for the final analysis
so this really was high-end and you're
absolutely right so if you use mass spec
you have the possibility to look at
everything and you get a unbiased view
which never would be possible with with
the West
if you got an idea where things are
happening the DTS might really be the
right thing and if you're looking at
phosphorylation it even might become
more interesting so not each of the
peptides which does carry a phosphor
group is easily detected using mass spec
things are really getting much better
and much much faster paced but still
having the the digi West might give you
complimentary data and mass spec and did
us as still CS something which is
complementary so another advantage of
the digi West but again you need to know
what you're looking at is that the
amount of material is low and it is
still much lower what you would need for
a mass spec analysis I would like to
once again thank dr. Marcus Champlain
and dr. Anthony Covey own for their
presentation gentleman do either of you
have any final comments no I hope that
everybody found the weapon are very
useful today and thank you to Marcus for
his excellent presentation well thank
you and speedy as well
gentlemen thank you so much now if we
weren't able to speak to you directly
today we'll be sure to follow up via
email thank you for taking part I would
also like to thank our sponsor cell
signaling technology for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing on our website through March
22nd 2017 we will let you know when it's
been posted and you hope we hope you
pass that information on to any
colleagues who could it take part in
today's broadcast thanks for joining us
see you next time goodbye